[Music]
when i was pre-op
oh the orgasms were good but honey
when i got that vagina
[Music]
how do you have sex are you able to have
penetrative sex
i am a post-op trans woman so that means
that i have undergone vaginoplasty
um which is a form of reconstructive
surgery and that allows me to be able to
have vaginal intercourse
it's actually really weird like having
sex with a vagina obviously because i
went
22 years of my life without one every
single time i'm like oh my god what if
it hurts or like what if it breaks or
what if i like have to get another
surgery or something personally i am
pre-op so i haven't had
a vaginoplasty and i don't plan on
getting one probably until i decide to
have children
just because i don't really have like
gender dysphoria as much like down there
it doesn't really bother me as much
i do the penetrating i guess
what is your sexual orientation if you
have a partner now
how do they identify um i'm straight
i am married to a heterosexual
cis male i would stay straight because i
am attracted to men
and the men that are attracted to me
also they would consider them straight
because they see
a female in me a lot of men are scared
to date trans women because they're
scared of
being gay in the eyes of other men i
don't have muscles i don't have hairy
legs i have nothing
that would attract a gay man to me you
know so
i don't consider my partner gay as it
stands now i would
identify as pan or
bi so i'm still married to my cisgender
wife we were married before my
transition
the vagina is still something that i am
exploring
and open to it isn't my number one
preference but i recognize that my
wife's number one preference wasn't at
the time having a
wife at what point do you disclose to
your potential partners that you're
trans
it's such a touchy subject because a lot
of girls disagree with me
but i believe that your first
conversation
point blank i wouldn't want to talk to
somebody
like have feelings for them and then
they find out that i'm trans and they're
not into it
which is totally fine because you know
it's not everyone's cup of tea and you
can't be mad at somebody because they're
not into you
but i definitely think that before you
do anything sexual with somebody you
need to disclose that you're trans that
is like a number one thing
so before my surgery um i think it was a
little more important i would literally
be with a guy and just like get caught
up in the moment and think he's like so
perfect so amazing and i was like wait
like i have to tell you something and
now having a vagina
um i've like fully had sex with people
and like just not even told them they
just like don't know
when guys get upset when they find out
you're trans it's honestly based off
their own insecurities of like oh i find
someone so attractive oh she used to be
a boy oh my god if you're attracted to
me if you
literally just had sex with me it
doesn't matter like
who i was born as like i'm not that
person anymore
have you ever feared for your safety
while pursuing a hookup
i was hooking up with a lot of people
without telling them i was trans
i had an instance one time where i was
hooking up with a guy
and one of my friends at the time who i
thought was my best friend
told him after i hooked up with him and
he lived in the same apartment building
as me and it was not
good him and his like friends starting
to beat my ass i literally had to move
out of my apartment because i was scared
like literally for my life
well i do sleep with like a bat and a
knife for sure
like i've thought to myself like two
[ __ ] do i have to grab my knife
i have been in bars where i've had guns
put up to my head here in california
honestly a couple months ago i was with
this guy and it was just going really
good
didn't expect like hook up with him or
anything but then one thing led to
another
obviously didn't tell him i was trans
because i didn't expect to hook up with
him he was like oh was like lila your
birth name and like started like
asking very like weird questions and he
was like oh your vagina like looks new
i didn't know where it was gonna go i
was like what if he like drugs me or
smothers me or literally kills me
because it happens all the time you have
to be so careful
and so i was like oh this is a really
unsafe situation like i have to go
are orgasms better after your transition
when you're more comfortable with your
body yes orgasms are better
when i was pre-op oh the orgasms were
good
but honey when i got that vagina
it feels so nice to just be able to just
let her just flow
just let it flow i think now that i'm on
like hormone pills
my libido went from here to like hear
when you're on hormones for so long
it does a lot to your reproductive
organs
so you don't produce sperm and your sex
drive goes down a lot
i almost went like a year without having
sex just because i really was like
not feeling well about myself because i
was still in kind of like that beginning
phase where i felt like i really wasn't
a full woman yet
my sex life with my partner has improved
since my transition
it can be magical and epically more
romantic
and epically more because i'm so much
more engaged i was never
able to be fully engaged with almost
anything across the spectrum of life not
just sex
before i came out it's much better much
more beautiful
how often do you encounter people who
fetishize you
um very often they go instantly into
like
oh like do you like the top you know can
i give you
oral there's always random people who
will
instagram dmu twitter damn you i've been
so many people who were like
oh my god do you have a dick or like
blah blah blah and think it was like
so hot and stuff like that and it's like
baby i'm not a fetish and like
that's what so many people like think or
they're like oh i'm not into that and
it's like
into what you're into girls like that's
it's like not
something to be into it's just like are
you attracted to me or not when you have
sex
do you ever struggle with feelings of
dysphoria
yes i do my voice and my
face for making out and sometimes my
stubble you know i haven't had laser
hair removal there are certain surgeries
facial feminization and things like that
that i
still haven't had i don't feel dysphoric
about my genitalia
a lot of trans people do i don't i like
that part of my body
i know so a lot of trans women are very
like against their parts
and you know because mentally they're
women right well
this is me trans women you know i'm i'm
not mentally a woman i don't want
ovaries i don't want a vagina
you know so i like using my penis to
have sex
for sure it's so important oftentimes as
a trans woman to feel that we need to be
the prettiest we need to be the thinnest
we need to be the curviest
just so we can't even feel less
dysphoric
early on i remember she even asked if it
was possible for me to
sometimes you know role play like the
role of uh
of a guy even just for like almost like
dress up i think she was just
coming to terms with the loss of that i
was very honest and said no
because i'll be in tears by the end of
that was sex
talked about in your heart growing up uh
no there was no sex talked about in my
home
i grew up in montgomery alabama so very
deep bible belt south so sex was not
talked about
at home and um i
actually had sex at 13. asian people
they have like this
like strict rule and like
also the way that um they want their
sons to grow up as
so if they're growing up trans like it's
kind of a big no-no
i told myself and i made a promise to
myself that i won't
transition medically until my mom like
fully accepts me
yeah she disowned me for like five years
i just wanted
that path for me i know that a lot of
trans girls would be like
xyla you need to take hormones right
away or else you're gonna turn into an
old man but
for me i wanted to do it my way
i mean now we're like best friends and
like she buys me underwear and like bras
and stuff
so is it transphobic if i want to wait
for sex until my partner gets further
into her transition
oh whoo that's a tricky one there's no
issue with wanting to wait and you need
to definitely communicate that
because it really sucks for someone to
have to wait
and expect something and it never comes
and then for also them
to have to feel that you really don't
desire them at all
no i don't think that's transphobic i
think honestly certain things especially
sexually with pre-op trans women is i
guess just your
like own opinion and your own preference
i guess like certain things make you
uncomfortable that's one thing but if
you genuinely don't want to have sex
with them then it's like why are you
together why are you talking like it's
like it's a conditional
kind of love it's like you don't view
them as
female or male until they're completely
transitioned which is not fair
if you can't love me at this point you
can't love me at this point
you know has sex ever made you regret
your transition
i would say no i don't think sex really
has anything to do
with my transition because i guess for
me like i could go the rest of my life
without
having sex not regret i would never ever
regret anything but
right after i got my surgery and like
got my first boyfriend i was like oh my
god why is this so much work like
because you have to dilate and like
clean yours like clean and like all this
stuff once you go that far
there's nothing really you can't handle
so it's just all about patience at that
point and like
letting everything heal and your day
will come i'm at a point
in my transition where like sex doesn't
give me any validation anymore
i think when i was younger that was
definitely an issue and i thought
i needed to be having so much sex to
have people really think you know that i
was the most perfect and beautiful woman
what's one thing you wish you could
debunk about being a trans woman
this whole like pervert thing and like
um you know us trans women using the
restroom it's like honey all we do there
is wash your hands
or pee or poop and then we're gone i am
not there to look
and stare at your anything one of the
things that i wish that we can debunk is
that
we often don't get tested we often
don't want to know our hiv status
people think that you know we're just
walking around you know just like i'm
walking a cd we're not
we just want to be normal we want to
live a life we want happiness we want to
boyfriends we want husbands we want to
not be killed we don't want to be
threatened
we don't want to be somebody secret we
don't want to be your side chick
every night i get texts from midnight to
five in the morning and it's so annoying
because those are whole hours and i'm
not nobody so i'm special
i'm unique
i wish that i learned
being trans isn't a sexuality it's a
identity like i thought because of my
own experience i thought okay all trans
women
who transition from male to female they
like men
but that's clearly not the case like you
can be trans or trans women and love
women
you can love both or you can love men i
wish that i would have learned that sex
has an equal love i think i wish
i would have realized that just because
i was 13 and i thought that i loved him
and we had sex so that meant that he
loved me too
the emotional connectivity
that comes from having sex with someone
after i've had sex with someone it has
never been the same
when i'm in the room with them when when
their name is brought up there's there's
a connection there that for better or
worse
those are pieces of me that i wish i had
guarded a little more in a lot of
circumstances
everyone should explore their own bodies
and find out
what is best for them you know it
shouldn't be
about making other people happy
or fulfilling a societal standard
sex is fun and it should be about that
[Music]